恐れをマネージメントに使っているから
悪い報告は隠そうとするのよ。その謝るの
は一時の辛さだけど長期的、本的客観的に
見て正直でやるっていうことが大切なん
じゃないかな。で、1つの仕事を複数の人
で確認をしてそういう仕組みを全部こう
組み合わせることによってミスを未然に
防げるようにしてるよね。
青木サ市の人生鉄学
100回聞いたら豊かになる話。
今回はですね、ま、職場において、ま、あの、やっぱり悪い報告早く上がってくるのがいいと
言われてると思うんですけれども、なんかつい隠しちゃうメンバーが何か悪いこととか失敗をした時にそれをつい隠そうとしてしまうそんな職場環境が、ま、なぜ生まれてしまうのか、ある意味の悪い報告が上がってこない職場の特徴について教えていただけますでしょうか?
なるほど。
ま、これ明解だよ。2つだよな。まず1つ
は上司がボスマねだよ。上司が悪いんだよ
。まずはうん。つまり恐れを
マネージメントに使っているから悪い報告
は隠そうとするのよ。まずこれ1つだよ。
で、もう1つは本人が悪い報告したら小心
昇格にも影響があるだろうし、自分損する
という利己的な思いがあるからだよ。この
2つですよ。じゃあどうしたらいいかって
言ったらすごい明解な。まず上司はボス
マ似をやめるってことだよ。うん。やめ
るつってそう簡単にやめれないんだよ。
これなんでかって言うと楽なんですよ。
そのが立場でも言う方がだ。批判する
責める文句を言う神々言う脅すバツを
与える目先の褒美で釣る。これはね立場が
ある方が使いやすいんですよ。だ、親は子
に使うし、先生は生徒に使うし、上司は
部下に使うし、この恐れが支配的、恐れと
か不安が引き出されるような、そういう
環境の中では隠蔽、悪いことは全部隠し
ますよ。でも隠しきれなくなって出てくる
わけよ。職場から恐れを取り除く、組織
から恐れを取り除く。これ簡単じゃないよ
、正直。っていうのは上司はさっきも言っ
たけどね、恐れを使った方が楽なんですよ
。立場でもの言えるから。あともう1つ
そのね、自分自身が自分の立場が悪くなる
というのが嫌だからと言ってフォーミーな
気持ちで、え、隠すというその利己的な
心理だよね。これも分からなくはないよね
。人はみんなそれはなるべくならもしたい
し自己正当化のストーリーを考えるし嘘と
いういろんなこうなんだろう取り作ろうと
かでなぜ人は嘘言うのかなって考えると
やっぱり恐れなんだよ。だから嘘の兄弟文
みたいなもんが言い訳なんだよね。で、
どんなね、その関係かって言うと防御され
た嘘なんですよ。言い訳っていうのは。だ
、そういう意味では言い訳がある職場は
恐れが支配している嘘がある職場もしくは
家庭組織にはまさに恐れが支配していると
だなるべくね恐れを取り除く。そして事実
問題として対処できるようにして上司は
移任責任と実行責任これを分けて移任責任
は上司が持つんですよ。
で、実行責任は本人に持たせ。上司のやはり移任の仕方にも問題があった。だ、そこのところはやっぱり問題に対しては一緒に解決していこうと力なってあげるとそういう風に歩み寄っていく方が僕は良いと思います。
ありがとうございます。
ちなみにその職場がもう恐れで満してるなってなった時に恐れを取り除くための
[音楽]
1歩目って何なんですか?
教育だよな。だからだからやっぱり情報に触れるってことでしょ。その恐れがどれほど非生産的な状態を作るのか。
昔はね、恐れがないと緊張しないといい
パフォーマンスを出せないっていう、そう
いう間違った思い込みの時代があったんだ
よ。ところが全部こう心理学的なデータと
かエビデンス取っていくと自分が自分の
仕事に対して責任を持って取り組んでいく
。自分の中でベストの仕事をしようという
思い込み、またそういう姿勢。それを持っ
ていれば角の恐れなんか必要ないし、
もっと言うと誰かに認められたいとかこの
人が怖いから頑張ろうなんていうのはこの
人がいなくなったらサボるじゃん。あの
良い教師っていうのはねやっぱり自己評価
を促す技術を持ってるよ。他者評価じゃ
なくて良い上司は子供だったら勉強、会社
だったら仕事の取り組みっていう質問に
なるんだけど自分にとってどう最善の選択
できてる。今の結果をどう見ている?この
限られた時間の中で今生み出してる
パフォーマンスは自分で何点つける?で、
こんな風に恐れなんかなくたってちゃんと
自己評価を促す質問してあげたらいい
じゃん。その時にメタ認知が非常に甘くて
ね、すっごいパフォーマンス低いのに
100点ですなんて言ったらおそうか。俺
も意外な答えだなつって。だけどお前これ
ねうちの会社だったら給料3年でまあ5倍
の付荷価値を生み出すというある1つ
みんなそれに取り組んでるけれど今君の
生み出してる価値って自分の報酬から見て
何倍数字って事実を語るからまだ1.5倍
です。
っていうことは何点自分でつけれるの?
やっぱり40点ぐらいでしょうか?
いやいや、40点って言わなくていいけど
、もうちょっと点数上げてもいいけど、
まだキャリアを形成してるプロセスだから
。ただ100点って言ってしまったらもう
伸び代なくなっちゃうよね。なんかできる
ことあるっていう風にして一緒にプランを
立てて成長させてああげたらいいでしょ。
そんな感じ。
ありがとうございます。
逆になんて言うんでしょう?なんかそのメンバー側の方がミスを報告するとやっぱりその自分がすごくこう低く見られるとか悪く思われるんじゃないか。ダメな人間だって思われたらどうしようって思っちゃってやっぱこう報告できないっていう職場の場合はなんかまずどんな関わりからした方がいいですかね?
[音楽]
ま、エドワードデミングっていう人があらゆる問題の
98%
はシステムであるとおっしゃったんだよね。
ま、急止コントロールという、ま、製造業
ではみんな勉強するようなことなんだけど
、僕はやっぱり仕組みシステムに問題が
あると思います。だからやっぱりチェック
システムとか毎日の報告のシステムとか
日報の仕組みだとかそれからやっぱり1つ
の仕事を複数の人で例えばうちで言うと経
をして出勤する人ともう1人確認を取る人
とかそういう仕組みを全部こう
組み合わせることによってミスを未然に
防げるようにしてるよね。38年経営して
きて大きなそういう問題がないのは、ま、
事前の一手は事後の100点にマさルで
やっぱり仕組みシステムをきちっとそこに
焦点を当ててきたからだよね。だからその
人の立場からって言われると過にやっぱり
こう恐れを持つ性格の人もいるだろうし、
ま、人の常だよね。自分の失敗隠したいっ
ていうのは。ただ隠したとしても結局それ
がま、あからさになった時はもっと大きな
問題を生むことになるわけじゃん。そこは
やっぱりね、な、何て言うのかな、勇気を
持って失敗を自分からすいませんでしたと
ちょっとご相談がありますという勇気、
そういう勇気を持つことを僕は進めたいよ
ね。つまりその謝るのは一時の辛さだけど
隠しと言って信用落としたり信頼できない
。あいつは信用できない。信頼できないっ
て言われたらもう職場に入れなくなっ
ちゃうじゃん。だからやっぱりそれは長期
的、本質的、客観的に見て正直でや
るっていうことが大切なんじゃないかな。
そんな風に思うけどね。俺その人そういう
ことほら隠す人間じゃないのでわかんねえ
わぶっちゃけそういう性格。うん。俺も
正直あ、すいませんって言うタイプだもん
。だってだってしょうがないじゃん。もう
してしまったんだから。結果は悪いんだ
からごめんなさいつって次に向かうしか
ないよ。いや、本当開きなるわけじゃない
けどと思うけどな、俺は。
ま、ですから家庭でやろうと学校でやろう
と職場であろうと恐れをマネジメントの
ベース、ま、いわゆる床っていう表現する
んだけど恐れの床を敷くとやっぱり隠蔽と
かプラスは何もないよね。それよりも責任
の床を敷いて自分がちゃんと責任を取れる
ように強く自分なりに何でもその恐れじゃ
なくてねすいませんでしたと勇気を持って
言えるようなやっぱりこう床を敷いて
あげる家庭であろうと学校であろうと職場
であろうとまそういうことが大事じゃない
かなと私は考えています。
是非、あの、今日のね、このメッセージ聞いた方、コメント欄に色々またコメントがあればお願いします。あと是非ねチャンネル登録もよろしくお願いします。また次回いましょう。お願いします。うん。どう?その辺は?
[音楽]
いや、おっしゃる通りだと思います。そうだよね。うん。
うん。
ありがとうございます。
でもね、岡口もさ、もう入社して今年で何年目なる?
年になります。15年だろ。
はい。
やっぱり自分で今マネージャーになるまでの間にさ、メンバーも見てきただろうしだから自分もやっぱりこう昔コンサルタントやってる時にね、やっぱりこうなんだろう失敗したことだとかなんことしてきたじゃん。うん。どう?その時自分自身、ま、うちの職場ってあんまりそんな恐れはないとは思うんだけどなんだろう。
自分の周りの同僚の中でそんなにうちの会社って隠す人っていないと思うんだけど自分だったらどんな風に対応したと思う?教えてくれよ。逆に俺わかんないもんぶっちゃけ。
いや、でもそれでいくと多分私はどっちかって言うとあのちっちゃい人間だったので
うん。うん。うん。
あの、嫌だなって、あの、失敗したことに対して思ってましたけど、どちらかというとやっぱり当時の上司たちが
やっぱりこう失敗したことに気づいた時になんて言うんでしょうね。こうそれをすごくやっぱり攻められることがなかった。攻めるではなくってやっぱりその原因を救命して、ま、次起きないようにしようねっていう、ま、リカバリーに回っていただいたみたいなところを、ま、ま、当たりにした時に、あの、すごくなんて言うんでしょうね。
この人たちに恥ずかしくない生き方をしたいなって思って育てていただいたなっていう感じです。
やっぱり人々は素晴らしいお前は。うん。そうだよな。でもそういう会社だよね。アチューメントはね。ま、どうしてもこうなんだろう。
上司側からはどういう風にしてあげられる
かって考えるけど、その隠してしまうその
弱さを持ってる人の個人のケア風になると
ちょっとなかなかね、やっぱりこう自分
たちがタイプじゃないと難しいところな。
うん。参考になりました。
勉強なりました。
におっしゃいますか?はい、
ありがとうございます。
[音楽]
決して負けない経営。まず経営者自身がお金よりも仕事の内容そのに惚れ込んでるかどうかです。